you see the interview he did with Lex
Friedman I saw some of it so I think
Alex is an absolute stud very just smart
thinker just Brainiac very logical actor
and I've never seen him get emotionally
triggered and he and Kanye did that yeah
so you can do that to the kind of a
rational logical guy it's Testament to
that but he made a very good point he's
like and this is where they went back
and forth back and forth he's like
listen stop with the group stuff
individuals screwed you over use their
names that's how you get even right Bill
[ __ ] me Rick Rubin [ __ ] whoever it is
yeah you can name them and that's how
you get even and that's how you even the
score
I mean I mean these African-American
singers in the 60s really did get
screwed and [ __ ] how did Kanye get
fight he's richer than he was rich well
hire a good Jewish lawyer to read your
[ __ ] contract Point number two I I
think that you talked about like Adidas
specifically or Balenciaga or Vogue
whatever I think there's a major
difference between a full-on brand a
fashion brand distancing themselves from
you versus a Spotify I'm totally okay if
Adidas wants to do their thing but let's
do your thing you don't want him
representing your brand but Spotify
that's his music
I'm totally against that like if he's if
he's rapping about killing Jews all
right maybe but he's not that's not what
it is so I'm fully against that yeah
thirdly and this is we're talking about
Jews and Assyrians you've dealt with
this before where you went into a room
to get a job to be a part of a company
and they're like yeah we don't we don't
do business with the Armenians or
Assyrians it just and you're like what
did I do you're like well we've had a
bad experience it's like Judge Me by the
content of my character not by Martin
Luther King and I think that's
ultimately what we're talking about here
absolutely you've dealt with this PVD
yeah I mean look here's here's the one
thing when I was watching maybe
yesterday there's there's a trend
there's a there's a difference between
being a troll
because it works the business model
troll is very effective it's a very very
effective business model to accelerate
uh getting eyeballs look at what Andrew
Tate did he got under people's skins and
Bone the most viral man on the internet
no one's getting more eyeballs and the
guy does an interview Boom everybody
wants to know what this guy's got to say
but there there's a thin line like Conor
McGregor was a very good smack talker
until he lost a fight to Dustin Podium
says hey tell your wife to stay out of
my DMs and then boom he crossed the line
there when you're talking about trolling
there's a line for trolling you don't
cross when him and Mayweather were
growing at it great it sold tickets we
were all curious uh you know the fight
when what nine or ten rounds but he was
a professional troller so was Mayweather
so was Trump so are a lot of these guys
Jake Paul major troller it's a very very
effective business model these days it
is it's generally always been though but
but the way it was done before was in a
different way Muhammad Ali and everybody
they were just Robert Maxwell you know
jerlane's father was a troll going after
Murdoch and Murdoch was trolling him
this trolling concept with Onassis
trolling John F Kennedy this is not a
new new thing right but the difference
is if I may social media has Amplified
that right because now you can do your
own distribution you don't have to rely
on no question about it you know
and then there is and then there is
like you know it's like you know
sometimes like uh you you're trying to
get attention you're trying to look
let's just say sometimes a podcast is
not doing good or show is not doing good
yeah and they're like man I gotta I
gotta show some boobs I gotta show some
This I Gotta show somebody I haven't
been getting a lot of likes on my
Instagram I gotta say some crazy [ __ ] to
you and then he's like no man now now
your business model is too reliant on
how everybody reacts to you and you lose
authenticity that's when you get up
again I don't know what anybody else
does because I've never had that in my
brain I've always tried to be as
authentic as I can and I try to to just
speak in a way that that hopefully
speaks to all groups because and and
we're going to keep repeating the same
thing but you know you want to troll
somebody you're pissed at somebody's
specific troll them specifically but
once you start lumping in groups it's
it's it's dangerous yeah but like I said
it's a long road part of me thinks Kanye
is this is all uh exactly what you're
talking about he's trolling all of us
and while he lost some money at the
moment he'll be back and I'll have an
album in a year and it'll be this and
and it'll be and it'll be huge you know
provided it's good well before the Jews
which is the the you know throughout
history they've been a major Escape but
right now obviously over the last couple
years it's been Asians yeah oh you're
Chinese clearly you've given everybody
Kobe like no yeah I'm from Vietnam I'm
from Hong Kong like stop looping
grouping me into this it's a very
slippery slope and it ends up getting a
work where it gets very up nobody did
that nobody did nobody did what nobody
said you're Chinese you're the one that
gave me the vibe are you kidding me
Asian hate was a real thing no nobody
did that that was that was that was what
no nobody did that was a campaign to pin
again the same thing he's been taught my
last three years is to pin bit of lacks
against whites CNN against Fox this is
the stuff that they make up that you
believe and you're like oh my God this
nobody did that nope I I never went to a
person saying yeah Kobe is because of
your fault but you didn't because you're
not an idiot no no but but people did do
it stop people I'm not gonna like this
is a real thing this is not a real thing
this is this is what this Asian people
have been beat up because of this there
are actual stories yeah and and real
life actual case examples yeah these
exact scenarios but why though but why
though because some people know elements
no Society no good [ __ ] idiots and
they'll take go to this give them an
inch they'll take them out go to the
seed go to the seed the root of the
issue is when a CNN or MSNBC or the
media says constantly this is what's
happening and then there is reaction to
it to get the attention that's why we
can't sit here and naively think people
are going around because somebody from
the top says Kobe came from these guys
and they're blame the same thing can be
said when they said covet is because of
the Trump's fault no covert is this
person's fault cover is that Prince's
fault so we can play that card all we
want the same story can be said on the
other side the moral of the story is the
best thing that Doug just said is the
final one I said he says I feel like
we're going backwards and I asked why he
says media and you turn on the media
broadcasting everybody hates each other
we don't we don't we don't hate each
other I mean we can sit down and have a
civil conversation and figure things out
you know we can sit down not everything
that happens is because people are
judging the other person one scenario
doesn't mean as a million scenarios
where people are being convinced one
instance of a issue happening is
happening a million times everywhere
it's not it's happening here and there
so the more you promote it it gets to
nine people 100 people 700 people 20 000
people that's how this kind of [ __ ] gets
started I don't disagree with that I'll
say one caveat it takes a seed to plant
a tree a million times yeah hear me out
here oftentimes a small story a real
story an actual case example of an Asian
guy getting beat up or a black guy like
a George Floyd getting killed what like
that actually happened the media will
water it and water it and give it
fertilizer and grow that [ __ ] and
amplify it but it did start with an
actual example do you remember the the
thing that was going viral in the
streets of New York where kids were
going around knocking people out and I
just pulled something the workout game I
think old people yeah just clocking them
whose fault was that yeah so say that
incident happened 20 times now all of a
sudden ever everybody is putting it out
there now other kids want to go do it
now their kids are noticing people are
becoming celebrities they record me
while I'm doing this you're feeding the
machine you're feeling the Beast well
the news is I mean it isn't even the
news anymore it's just fear-mongering
and you know and it's it's honestly it's
not even new though I remember when I
moved to LA and I'm from New York you
know I grew up with murderers and stuff
and when I got to La everyone's like
they carjack you in La be real careful
and I remember in La I would drive
around Beverly Hills in 1990 and like
pull up like eight feet from a red light
so I could [ __ ] Escape if anyone
attacked me and it is you watch the news
or whatever they want to call the news
and every five seconds they are showing
you something that you should be scared
of and they're not really giving you any
way out of it they're not giving you
like news should be okay there's a
hurricane coming you might want to get
out no you know not um you know
everybody's getting killed every five
well I don't remember you Doug you're a
little bit older than me but I don't
know if you remember but news used to be
a non-monetizable a monetizable asset it
was the news they weren't looking to
make money off of it it was a it was
almost like a free thing for society and
when they started to monetize news oh we
can make money off this oh the bigger
personalities and the more
sensationalized that we can do things
this is a cash cow this is a money maker
let's get some people that get eyeballs
and now today with social media and
amplification changed butt and I know
everybody loves like Cronkite and stuff
but the reality is it's it's still you
know even when you're reporting news
even if it was 30 years ago it's skewed
by somebody's vision of what they think
of who who's being oppressed or who's
this what they want to show whether it
was Vietnam or whatever it was so
um it's it's a scary thing but at the
same time we need it because you need
access and that's why free speech is so
important but right now it's also the
really hard thing I mean you can just
read the New York Times and then you can
go read somewhere else something the
exact same story and you go holy [ __ ]
yeah that was like I don't know what to
think anymore except I do know that the
times has got a liberal slant to it no
matter what they want to claim so it
it's a very confusing time and it's a
scary time for for young people
especially and and you know I think I
think what we're seeing with like the
mental illness crisis is because people
are so [ __ ] up and they are so kind of
lost as to which way to turn and and
hopelessness a little bit I think is
entering the equation where you just go
what the [ __ ] is the point we can't you
know have a normal minute ever so yeah
and don't forget speaking of like Legacy
Media back in the day was three major
Outlets yeah ABC NBC CBS and then Fox
showed up in the 90s it's like who are
these new guys on the Block yeah right
and that and now there's 10 billion
different channels go get whatever you
want there's something for you yeah I
didn't change the game tattoo under is a
legendary guy who started a business
model which was 24 7 news and everybody
thought that was crazy he almost wristed
up he risked it all and then next thing
you know he ends up buying the Falcons
buying the Braves I don't know who he
bought he freaking pretty much bought
half the world and then he ran for
office he almost became a president so
Ted Turner created that model of
constant news which seemed really good
yeah and it was and it was really good
and now you look at it but it's weird
even with CNN now unless I'm crazy
because I stopped watching it during the
pandemic I mean Cuomo and Don Lemon were
getting me to the point of like you know
everybody hates if one side hates Tucker
Carlson one side hates I hate both of
them I just think they are good you know
I think they're a lot better to live
that way yeah I mean I just think they
are trying everything they can to make
everyone hate each other and they're
laughing all the way to the bank because
they get paid to do this but CNN I feel
like unless I'm crazy I've clicked on a
little bit I feel like they've moved a
little right all of a sudden like
suddenly they've not they're trying to
get back
with the new CEO firing a bunch of
people and getting rid of a bunch of
people but
the CNN I'm talking about if you ever
read the book by Ted Turner okay I don't
know if you've read it or not I have not
highly recommended it he wrote this a
while back I will because I like tattoo
oh my god dude you're gonna have you
won't be able to put it down it's that
if you download the audiobook and on
your flight back you finish it you'll be
able to finish it at 1.5 speed what's
the name of the book it's called Ted I
think they call me Ted I think that's
what 1.5 speed I do 2.0 I do 2.0 this
guy would go 4.0 if he could I'm gonna
you can on Spotify 3.5 and it's
fantastic but but going back go back to
this going back to this when you hear
How It Ends
what what his level of disappointment
with CNN how the book ends and this is
not a new book can you pull up the book
just just type in what the uh uh Ted
Turner book it's not a it's not a new
book it's an older book not Teddy that's
a porn
it autocorrects it's too early say they
call me Teddy call me
oh my God time
call me that book right there yeah by
the way it's 13 years old which is
perfect because nothing was happened it
wasn't like 13 years old so that book is
due for a bar mitzvah oh that sounds
like 09 is what it is so but CNN was a
guy that changed the game and everything
else came after that I will say
something about CNN
um no doubt nationally it has a tainted
image in my opinion and from what I talk
to especially people are actually CNN
International has a different cachet
globally like CNN International which
obviously we don't watch one of the
states does still have a high level of
credibility and that's essentially you
know the international arm of what Tim
was so you watch a lot of CNN
Internationals they actually do very
very I'm thinking about what they're
thinking over a little bit around the
world
they just think they're a third world
country think about it it's not as you
know us-based left right you know
conservative liberal Trump yes no
Dynamics right it's just international
news so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]